So as bad as the July 3rd speech at Mount
Rushmore was for Donald Trump and certainly
the July 3rd speech contained way more verbal
glitches.
It was what we're calling benzodiazepine.
Trump by previously referred to it as Downar
Trump.
Sometimes we say Ambien trump.
The July 4th speech on the lawn of the White
House was absolutely terrifying.
And Donald Trump actually taking some of the
same ideas from July 3rd about we're fighting
Marxists here in the United States.
And actually building on them in an even more
cartoonish and dystopian way.
Trump's big messages, recycled things from
the previous night were essentially we have
agitators and looters and anarchists and Marxists
that we are fighting against.
We are now in the process of defeating the
radical left, the Marxists, the anarchists,
the agitators, the looters and people who
in many instances have absolutely no clue
what they are doing.
What Marxists are we fighting, like, please
find me an actual Marxist with any power whatsoever
that Donald Trump is fighting against.
I tweeted yesterday prepped preparing for
this segment.
Can someone send me the name of a specific,
powerful Marxist that Trump is fighting against?
And someone sent me an article about some
Black Lives Matter person is a, quote, trained
Marxist.
I had never heard of her.
And with all due respect, it's not someone
who is in any way wielding any amount of power
that would be comparable to what Donald Trump
has with the bully pulpit.
Like if that's the woman that Trump is fighting
when he says we are fighting Marxists, then
it's a really weird fight for Trump to actually
have to wage.
Now, there were also no shortages of glitches.
Here is Donald Trump struggling to say sweeping,
says swift.
Swift being swift, swift.
Completely incoherent.
Again, this was tweeted widely with people
saying, wait.
People are saying Biden has dementia.
How do you explain this?
Take a look.
They delivered a swift and swift.
And, you know, that's sweeping.
It was swift and it was sweeping.
Like nobody's ever seen anything happen.
Just barely able to get the words out.
White knuckling the lectern engaged in a battle
to the death with his own tongue.
All really, really wacky.
Now, eventually, he got to the point in his
force of 4th of July speech where he just
lists historical figures.
He did this July 3rd at Mount Rushmore.
Already played that for you.
Here is Donald Trump just list listing historical
figures on his July 4th speech.
And the crowd sort of actually does start
clapping.
I guess it was the the most exciting thing
that Trump said.
George Washington.
Thomas Jefferson, Betsy Ross, Alexander Hamilton,
Benjamin Franklin, John Adams, James Madison,
Dolly Madison, the great Frederick Douglass.
How weak are these applause lines?
Right.
Just listing people for the crowd to clap.
And it went on like that for a while.
I don't want to subject you to the entire
thing.
Another really strange applause line was when
Trump mentioned that the virus came from China.
People just starting to clap at the mention
of that fact.
Take a look.
But there and then we got hit by the virus
that came from China.
And we've made a lot of progress, our strategy
is moving along well.
Now, I don't I don't at this point want to
spend a ton of time on the China stuff.
The real message here is what a deranged Fourth
of July speech.
But it is interesting how in these China discussions,
it's never mentioned that China was the source
of the virus for every country.
Like if if the virus originated in China,
Spain was dealing with a virus that came from
China.
Italy dealt with a virus that came from China.
New Zealand dealt with a virus that came from
China.
So the fact that it came from China doesn't
change that.
Just about every other country dealt with
the virus better than the United States.
OK.
Brazil is a disaster.
India and Russia are not doing well.
I've heard of some small countries that are
not doing well.
But the fact that it came from China, how
does that even bear applause?
And of course, it has no bearing on the fact
that Trump completely failed in terms of his
dealing with the virus.
But I don't want to focus too much on the
virus today.
But again, Donald Trump during his Fourth
of July speech goes into the only reason we
have so many cases is because we have so much
testing.
Likewise testing.
There were no test for a new virus.
But now we have tested almost 40 million people.
By so doing, we show cases, 99 percent of
which are totally harmless results that no
other country can show because no other country
is testing that we have not in terms of the
numbers or in terms of the quality.
Remember, we've got to fact check it.
Trump says ninety nine percent of cases aren't
harmful.
That's not true.
It seems that the death rate is about one
percent.
But that doesn't mean ninety nine percent
are harmful.
Many more people are ending up in the hospital.
We still have questions about the long term
health effect, even in people who do recover.
So that's wrong.
Our testing per capita is still just twenty
sixth in the world are deaths per capita are
the ninth highest in the world.
Out of more than 200 countries and territories
that have cases.
So the narrative continues to be completely
untrue.
But his followers love it and they fall for
it.
And then sort of to wrap up the Fourth of
July speech, just one more clip.
Here is Trump saying that the media slanders
him when they accurately report that something
he said was either racist or xenophobic.
These are great heroes.
Let me also say a word to those in the media
who falsely and consistently label their opponents
as racists, who condemn patriotic citizens
who offer a clear and truthful defense.
Of American unity.
That's what our people are doing.
We want a clear and faithful defense of American
history.
And we want unity when you level these false
charges.
You not only slander me, you're not only slander
the American people, but you slander generations
of heroes who gave their lives for America.
This is just hilariously and laughably nonsensical
when you call Trump out for doing something
racist.
You are slandering the troops that served
in the military in all of American history,
is what Trump is saying when you point out
Trump did something racist.
You are disrespecting people who served in
World War Two in Vietnam.
Like how?
How does that even compute?
And that's what Trump is trying to convince
people of.
And sadly, it works.
I tweeted yesterday that this will work on
some of his followers.
A bunch of people responded saying, David,
you're wrong.
This will work on most of his followers from
the rally, at least it seemed that that did
resonate with people.
When the media calls Trump racist, they are
disrespecting the troops.
If you convince people of that in Orwellian
fashion, it's almost more reminiscent of the
Testament's.
And oh, my God, what is Margaret Atwood's
first book before the Testament's that The
Handmaid's Tale?
It's more reminiscent of the type of propaganda
you see depicted by Margaret Atwood in A Handmaid's
Tale and the Testament's.
And it's working on his followers, which is
why, even though the polls look good for Joe
Biden, I know it's going to be an uphill battle
going into November.
We'll have continued coverage of this on The
David Pakman Show Instagram page at David
Pakman.
Show four pictures of me at the beach, which
are triggering men and women alike for very
different reasons.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
I'm half kidding, but I'm not kidding.
We'll be right back in two minutes.